with concerns growing over the speed of
vaccine rollout trump officials are in
talks to cut some of those doses in half
to make sure millions more get
vaccinated jeff paul with more on this
he's live in santa monica california hi
jeff
hey data yeah moderna right now is
discussing with the federal government
about
giving out half doses in order to speed
up vaccinations officials
with operation war of speed say there's
evidence that when given to people who
are
younger to middle age i think 18 to 55
that it shows about the same
immune response as giving the full doses
but the fda will have the final say on
this but something
has to be done as numbers continue to
surge throughout the country especially
right here
in southern california the original goal
set by operation
warp speed was 20 billion people
vaccinated by now to date
14 million vaccines have been
distributed but only a third of those
shots have been used but it's not
because of lack of demand
seniors in florida lined up for hours in
the hopes that they would get a shot
still despite this vaccine distribution
being a lot slower than anticipated
dr anthony fauci says there are some
signs things are moving
in the right direction but some little
glimmer of hope is that in the last 72
hours
they've gotten 1.5 million doses into
people's arms which is an average
of about 500 000 a day which is much
better
than the beginning when it was much much
less than that
now the uk meanwhile is likely headed
for tougher restrictions prime minister
boris johnson
is set to outline a new plan in about 30
minutes from now
the country has seen a massive surge in
coronavirus cases in the past few weeks
and is
was the first to discover that newer
more contagious variant of the
virus meanwhile scotland already ahead
of that saying they're going into a
lockdown starting tuesday where
people can't be going outside unless
it's for like essentials
or medical care dana yeah
and talking to family there thank you